ces gens que vous appelez à ces gens
c'est très facile de les citer mais dans
votre texte vous les nommez vous dit que
ce sont des hordes des hordes de
banlieue donc ne sais pas quel est le
degré de respect vous attacher à ces
gens je vous ai laissé parler donc
j'aimerais finir je ne sais pas quel est
le degré de respect vous attacher à ces
gens c'est vous vous instrumentaliser
ces questions et vous êtes en train de
nous expliquer qu'en gros pour des
scooters volés des boîtes aux lettres
cassées parce que je retrouve haute
expression faut envoyer l'armée et c'est
à dire des militaires armés de fusils à
pompe et un masque bah je suis désolé
moi je suis pas d'accord je pense qu'on
peut régler les choses autrement parce
que votre tribune vise précisément à
dire que puisqu'il ya une insécurité du
quotidien mais c'est pas le rôle de
l'armée de régler insécurité du
quotidien monsieur pardon c'est le rôle
de la police éventuellement on peut
avoir un débat là-dessus mais je refuse
et moi je vous le dis je l'assument je
refuse de reprendre le terme du débat
avec vous nous parlez de hordes de
banlieue comme si les gens étaient des
animaux alors que vous avez des
départements au pull r comme la
seine-saint-denis qui sont qui est le
département le plus pauvre de france
mais lui tient contributeur en termes de
protection sociale c'est-à-dire des
départements solidaire où les gens se
lèvent le matin pour livrer vos colis
pour livrer votre nourriture pour faire
tourner vos métro vautrin et vos
services publics notamment dans le
système de santé et vous la seule le
seul mot que vous avez pour ces gens
dans votre tribune c'est de les traiter
de hordes comme si tous les gamins de
ces quartiers étaient étaient des bêtes
sauvages pas pardon monsieur mais c'est
une tribune d'extrême droite vous
négligez les gens voulaient méprisé
voulait salissez effectivement je ne
suis pas d'accord avec vous pour
débattre sur cette base là ça me paraît
évident quand même
[Musique]